je vais vous parler de benjamins 1 et
mes camarades des classes au lycée
benjamin c'était le genre de personne
que tout le monde l'aimé bien et ils
étaient bons à l'école pourquoi je vous
raconte tout ça puisque benjamin c'était
la première personne déficiente visuelle
que j'ai connu personnellement il voyait
un peu il voyait les grandes formes et
les contrastes nommé pour pouvoir suivre
les cours normalement avec nous
l'utiliser une caméra qui filmait
agrandissez les contenus du tableau
benjamin nous accompagner aussi en
voyage de classe
je me rappelle notamment on a visité le
parlement européen à bruxelles et
benjamin nous suivait partout et le
prenais du plaisir à voyager mais il ya
une chose qui m'a toujours rendu triste
c'est que benjamin dépendait de nous
pour visiter cette nouvelle ville qui ne
connaissait pas vous avez tous déjà
sûrement vu une personne non voyante qui
se déplace en ville avec une canne
blanche et peut-être vous êtes vous déjà
posé la question comment est ce que ces
personnes peuvent se déplacer naviguer
sans voir leur environnement
les premiers chercheurs qui ont
travaillé sur cette question dans les
années 1930
c'était des chercheurs en psychologie
expérimentale en donner une réponse et
c'était les personnes non voyantes ne
serait pas capable de se créer une
représentation montagne de l'espace ou
seulement pour des structures familière
aux simples alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire par exemple et en envoyant pour y
apprendre où se trouvent les meubles
dans son appartement mais pourrait pas
mémoriser l'emplacement de ruth du
routes et bâtiments dans une ville
avant d'aller plus loin pour les
déficients visuels
réfléchissons à notre utilisation de
cartes géographiques
comment est ce que vous faites quand
vous visitez une nouvelle vie que vous
ne connaissez pas pour moi c'est la
première fois qu'on pionnier et moi j'ai
regardé une carte géographique
avant de venir donc je regarde soit les
cartons papiers soient les cartes
d'interactif c'est bien pratique parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a toujours son
smartphone avec nous et puis ça nous
donne accès aux cartes géographiques
presque partout
mais malgré cela je connais le sentiment
de me sentir perdus dans une ville que
je visite pour la première fois et je
pense que vous aussi avait déjà vécu
cette situation
alors maintenant faisons une expérience
je vous invitais fermer les yeux
vraiment alesi je vous dirais que c'est
le moment de rouvrir
imaginez vous êtes non voyons et vous
allez un train à la gare de pessac mais
que vous n'avez jamais visité avant vous
arrivez en train vous sortie du train
vous sentez les vents sur le visage vous
entendez les autres passagers qui parle
et puis vous allez vous voulez aller à
l'hôtel mais vous ne voyez pas où se
trouve l'hôtel
et puis comme vous vous mettez à un
marché vous ne voyez pas les obstacles
et les voitures ça fait peur n'est ce
pas alors ouvrez les yeux et je vais
vous donner une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle
je vais commencer par la mauvaise
avec le vieillissement les risques
d'être atteints d'une déficience au
monde
en fait à l'âge de 75 ans une personne
sur cinq en france à des déficiences
visuelles importante ça concerne au
total deux cent mille personnes en
france et donc vous et moi on a quand
même un risque un jour d'être atteintes
d'une déficience visuelle grave mais
comme je disais j'ai aussi une bonne
nouvelle
et donc c'est que les recherches ont
avancé depuis
depuis les années 1930 et aujourd'hui
les chercheurs en psychologie
expérimentale savent que les personnes
non voyantes sont tout à fait capables à
se représenter l'espace en fait le
développement des capacités cognitives
spatiales et plus long chez les
personnes non voyantes que chez les
personnes voyantes
mais à l'âge adulte une personne non
voyante peut mémoriser et à prendre les
informations spatiales autant qu'une
personne voyante
après on va observer les différences
entre les personnes qui ont passé une
partie de la vie avec la vue et ceux qui
ont jamais vu mais en tout cas c'est
possible
et puis aujourd'hui on sait faire des
cartes géographiques qui sont
accessibles donc vous voyez ici une
carte
ça s'appelle en plans tactiles ou alors
une carte en relief alors qu'est ce que
c'est une carte qui est imprimé sur un
papier spécial et c'est papier permet de
faire des structures qui sortent du
papier donc tout ce qui est en noir à
être soulevées donc une personne voyante
peu exploré cette carte avec les mains
et sentir les structures et puis vous
voyez il ya des lettres en braille qui
sont qui sont rajoutés qui donne les
informations supplémentaires cette carte
là montrent les plans d'un bâtiment est
gelée vu chez pierre pierre c'est un ami
qui est presque non voyons et les
passionnés des cartes et atlas tactile
il a toute une collection de ces cartes
à la maison et passent du temps à les
lire et la lecture de ces cartes permet
à pierre non seulement de se déplacer
selon bill d'aller travailler mais aussi
de voyager seul dans des pays qui l'a
jamais visité bon j'avoue que pierre
c'est aussi en avant tu es donc ces
cartes sont très bien pour donner accès
aux informations géographiques pour les
personnes non voyantes maison quand même
des limites
par exemple il faut savoir lire le
braille et puis contrairement à ce qu'on
pense ce n'est pas le cas de toute la
population non voyantes
en fait en france il ya seulement 15 %
des déficients visuels qui savent lire
le braille
donc on veut faire des cartes qui sont
accessibles mais on exclut toujours une
partie de la population et c'est pour
cela que depuis une trentaine d'années
des chercheurs en interaction
homme-machine travaille sur des cartes
interactif accessible sur cette photo
vous voyez le prototype que nous avons
conçu donc moi avec mes anciens
collègues de toulouse et l'utilisent
donc une carte un écran tactile en fait
donc c'est ce que vous avez dans votre
smartphone mais en plus grand
cette école est mis à plat et les
recouverte par une carte en relief
donc la même chose que vous avez vu
avant pour le plan du bâtiment donc on
peut toujours explorer la carte des
sentiers les structures mais au lieu
d'avoir du braille
on va rajouter des informations sonores
donc les non voyants peuvent par exemple
appuyé
et on entend les noms de rues les noms
de les bâtiments les distances entre
deux points ou même les horaires
d'ouverture ces plans permet de rajouter
plus d'information qu'une carte
traditionnelle en braille avec du relief
alors je vous avais parlé des capacités
à se créer des représentations mentales
et nous aussi nous sommes intéressés à
cette question nous avons donc invité
des personnes non voyantes de tester
notre prototype de carte mais aussi une
carte en relief avec du braille et nous
avons démontré que ces nouvelles type de
carte d'actifs peuvent être aussi aussi
efficace pour c'est pour apprendre les
informations spatiales ou géographique
que les cartes existantes avec du vrai
mais en plus c'est cela la plupart des
personnes étaient plus rapides avec la
carte interactif et c'est pas très
difficile à imaginer que c'est une bonne
chose si vous pouvez avoir accès à des
informations géographiques plus
rapidement et puis la plupart des
personnes ont préféré la carte d'actifs
en fait aujourd'hui les déficients
visuels utilisent déjà pas mal les
nouvelles technologies par exemple un
ordinateur pour aller sur internet
ou alors une tablette ou un smartphone
ils savent que ces technologies peuvent
leur donner accès à des informations qui
ne seraient pas accessibles autrement et
donc ça ne leur fait pas forcément peur
d'utiliser ces technologies et
finalement nous avons vu que cette carte
était accessible à une personne qui ne
savaient pas lire le braille
donc nous avons rencontré une personne
qui avait 80 ans au moment où il a pu
tester notre prototype il avait perdu la
vue à l'âge de 65 ans et comme je viens
de vous dire elle est très difficile à
prendre les bras et si on perd la vue
tardivement donc il avait jamais
vraiment appris le braille et ça faisait
des années qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
accéder aux informations géographiques
et ils étaient très contents que
finalement c'était possible je vous ai
aussi beaucoup parlé du déplacement
ville et je vous ne cache pas que notre
prototype est trop grand et trop lourd
pour l'amener en déplacement mais c'est
normal parce que ce n'était pas
l'objectif de nos études
en fait en ne visait pas les faire un
gps nomade il ya d'autres chercheurs qui
se travaille sur cette question
je vous ai dit au début avant de venir
ici moi j'ai regardé une carte
géographique et j'utilise aussi un gps
quand je conduis la voiture en fait
j'utilise les deux et pour les non
moyens aussi c'est intéressant d'avoir
accès aux deux un autre avantage pour
les cartes géographiques
c'est qu'ils peuvent aussi servir pour
l'enseignement et notre prototype est
ainsi aujourd'hui utilisée à l'institut
des jeunes aveugles de toulouse pensée
nier la géographie à des jeunes
déficients visuels
alors c'est pas tout à fait la carte que
vous voyez ici en fait j'ai une carte de
france et les déficients visuels peuvent
ainsi explorer les régions de la france
où les villes de la france
et puis entendre des chansons bretonnes
et puis les gens qui parlent basque
je suis très contente que du coup nos
recherches contribuer à l'éducation des
jeunes déficients visuels
mais mon rêve serait d'aller encore plus
loin pour que en 2050
même pierre et benjamins auront accès à
ce type de carte
comment peut-on y arriver une limite de
notre prototype actuel c'est le besoin
d'imprimer ses cartons un relief pour
recouvrir l'écran alors ça demande un
travail manuel
il faut des experts il faut du matériel
spécial et donc pas tout le monde peut
le faire mais il ya des chercheurs
nantais ac sur machine qui travaillent
sur des écrans qui seront déformable qui
peuvent donc eux-mêmes créé ces
structures donc imaginé un écran qui est
plat mais au moment où on en a besoin et
en relief qui sort je peux donc sentir
des structures et pise le relief il
disparaît comme je ne je n'ai plus
besoin
je suis sûr que c'était que nous vivons
arrivé en 2050 ou même bien avant et ça
va révolutionner la vie des déficients
visuels
et c'est ainsi que possible par exemple
sans smartphone de démontrer les
emplacements des différentes icônes pour
les trouver plus facilement et pour les
cartes géographiques ça sera possible de
les rendre plus dynamiques
par exemple d'utiliser un zoom ou plus
juste déplacer la vue sur la carte ou
peut-être d'afficher le trafic en temps
réel alors en 2050
benjamin pierre pourront utiliser les
cartes géographiques comme je le fais
déjà moi aujourd'hui
j'aimerais bien que vous êtes ne
contenait trois choses aujourd'hui
la première c'est que les personnes non
voyantes peuvent apprendre des
informations spatiales et c'est créer
des représentations de deux
l'informatique peut être utile pour
donner accès aux informations
géographiques et puis les soutenir dans
la tech d'orientation et finalement le
monde numérique est un formidable moyen
pour augmenter la qualité de vie des
personnes déficientes
je voudrais massy